[موسيقى]
موجودين في كمان عدوان رغم انه الظروف
اللي كانت والانتهاكات اللي انتهكها
الاحتلال كم عدوان غير مؤهله لاستقبال
المصابين لا يوجد فيها اشعه لا يوجد فيها
طاقه حاليا يعني بس مشغله كطو ئ اطفال
استقبال اطفال فقط طب عننا هي قسم استقبال
الاطفال استقبال الاطفال ما كان هيك
استقبال الاطفال كان مدمر تماما حاولنا
قدر الامكان تصليح
وتحسين المكان الموجود ما بنقدر نقدم كل
المساعدات حتى الموجوده للاطفال والادويه
اللي كانت موجوده حاليا غير موجوده في
الاقسام يعني لو بدنا نحكي انه اكسجين لا
غير موفر للاطفال فتوفر عننا كثير حالات
في مستشفى كمال عدوان لو بنا نيجي هي قسم
العنايه المركزه قسم الينان مركزه غير
مؤهله تماما لاستقبال اي طفل موجود عننا
لا يوجد فيها لا كهرباء لا اجهزه لا
اكسجين لا يوجد فيها اي نوع من تقديم
المساعده للاطفال طبعا عننا برضه غرفه سحب
عينات سحب العينات بس بنسحب سي بي سي فقط
لانه ما في كمان اجهزه ل خال العينات ما
في كهرباء قسم الاطفال تقريبا حاليا كانوا
عننا مبيت ما يقارب ع حالات العش حالات
هذول انه قدر الامكان بنحاول
نساعدهم انه بس يعني يعيشوا لكن ما في
اكسجين ما في لا هدول اطفال مصابين من
اثار الحرب هي عننا طفل مصاب
حرق هذا طفل مصاب حرق لا يوجد له اي علاج
لتقديم
الحروق
من بعد ما طلعت ما عرفتني وانصدمت ولحتى
الان وهي
مصدومه ما بتزعق بتزعق ماما ماما بابا
بابا بس هي مش
عارفان صابت في رجلها تقطع اوتار وكسر
وعندها خدوش في راسها ودمها سته بنتي هاي
انصدمت وحراره
عاليه و مش مصحصحات لسه عندي اولاد
الثلاثه هناك كمان مصدومين بيسقوا في
الليل على صط بس بدنا امنا بدنا ابونا
واحنا مش عارفين يعني سبعه نفار اللي
طلعوا من تحت
الردم سبعه من 15 نفر هذه اثار تحت الردم
كم يوم قعدت تحت
الردمي يوم كامل تحت الردم وبعدين جبونا
اياها على كمال عدوان طبعا هذه تحت الرد
بتحتاج اكسجين لصح نشبك عليها اكسجين ما
في عندي اكسجين اشبك كلها
اياه هذا الطفل الولد في الحرب 8 ع
انولد من يوم ما انولد لليوم ه هو في
المستشفى معه نزله معويه سخانه نتق وسال
مش راضي يروح عنه هي ثالث مره يبات في
المستشفى من يوم من
ولد هذه معاناتنا في قطع غزه ومعاناتنا
بشكل عام في شمال قطع غزه وخصوصا المستشفى
الوحيده الحاليا شغاله وهي مستشفى كمال
عدوان المندوبه عن كل مستشفيات قطاع غزه